redresser l'économie tout en contenant
l'épidémie de kovy 19 l'équation
s'annonce donc délicate pour le
gouvernement dans son plan de
déconfinement et voir philippaerts
insisté sur la nécessaire reprise du
travail dès le 11 mai prochain on en
parlait quitte à favoriser le
télétravail
à l'heure où plus de 11 millions de
salariés sont au chômage partiel quelle
sortie crise peut-on envisager un retour
à la normale est il possible où va-t-on
vers une explosion du chômage
on voit cela tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir que l'on
retrouve via skype aujourd'hui encore
bienvenue jacques
[Musique]
alors jacques le gouvernement fait face
à un véritable choix cornélien ans n'est
ce pas oui absolument
on a compris dans les annonces faites
par edouard philippe à l'assemblée
nationale que la stratégie du
gouvernement est donc de remettre la
france au plus vite au travail tout en
évidence que l'on appelle la deuxième
vague
c'est à dire en réalité une résurgence
explosive de l'épidémie mais cela
confronte au gouvernement un véritable
dilemme alors que le confinement est en
train en réalité de détruire l'économie
française comment éviter le pire
alors que certains de nos voisins en
particulier l'allemagne des confine bien
plus vite que nous alors peut-être
jacques tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dresser un tableau de l'état
de l'économie française après un mois et
demi de confinement est tout à fait
raison olivier ses parents cela qu'il
faut commencer et bien actuellement nous
savons que +2 55% des salariés du
secteur privé sont en chômage partiel
l'économie tourne donc au ralenti en
dessous en réalité 2 50% de son activité
normale alors comme on peut le voir sur
le tableau qui s'affiche
lindsay avait fait des estimations qui
était relativement optimiste à la fin du
mois de mars
elle a réitéré ses estimations au début
du mois d'avril dans mon propre
laboratoire au s'est mis nous étions
déjà nettement plus pessimiste et la
différence venait de ce que nous avions
tout d'abord cherché à estimer la perte
en productivité induite par le
télétravail
ce que n'a pas fait l'insee est que nous
pensions aussi que la contraction du
secteur des services était bien plus
importante que ce que l'insee estimé
c'est ce qui peut expliquer probablement
que l'insee et le gouvernement
avec cet institut et eu tendance à
sous-estimer l'ampleur de la crise à
venir du moins jusqu'à ces derniers
jours et pour essayer pour ce qui est de
l'impact sur l'emploi pôle emploi
annonce
une nette remontée du chômage en mars
2020 oui oui oui absolument
les chiffres du premier trimestre pour
les demandeurs d'emploi sont en train de
repartir à la hausse et cela pour toutes
les catégories
alors pour les deux catégories qui sont
réellement les plus représentatifs du
chômage on voit que il y à une remontée
alors que ce soit pour la fameuse
catégorie a mais aussi pour les
catégories bd qui sont des catégories
très proche de la catégorie a et cette
augmentation est tout à fait sensible en
particulier sur le mois de mars
alors il faut dire là est une chose
importante que les mesures du mois de
mars ont en réalité été marqué par tout
ce qui s'est passé dans la deuxième
quinzaine du mois de mars
donc ce que l'on pense comme une
remontée elle est concentrée sur les
deux dernières semaines de mars
alors jacques notre économie et donc en
grande partie à l'arrêt est-ce que cela
compte pour le plan de déconfinement oui
absolument olivier c'est tout à fait
évident ainsi on peut penser que la
décision du premier ministre de rouvrir
les crèches et des écoles communales a
pour véritable but en réalité de libérer
les parents et de leur permettre de
reprendre le travail
d'ailleurs rappelé dans de nombreux
autres pays comme par exemple l'italie
ou le royaume uni
les écoles ne rouvriront qu'en septembre
et dans ceux qui ont décidé de rouvrir
leur école dès maintenant à peu près en
même temps que nous et bien en réalité
fait rentrer plus tôt les lycéens des
grandes classes dont on peut
raisonnablement estimer dont on peut
attendre qu'ils respecteront eux les
fameux gestes barrière alors jacques ce1
déconfinement qu' edouard philippe a
annoncé comme est très progressif
peut-il permettre d'empêcher une forte
montée du chômage dans les mois à venir
dont olivier hélas non et vous avez
raison d'ailleurs de dire que le
déconfinement tel qu'il a été proposé
par le premier ministre sera très
progressive et cela aura d'ailleurs des
conséquences importantes sur l'économie
alors ici encore nous avons cherché au
s'est mis à simuler l'impact du
déconfinement de l'économie et nous
sommes arrivés en fait à trois cours à
la première cour la courbe eu un qui est
en bleu correspond aux prévisions du
gouvernement elle donne une chute du pib
de moins 10% pour l'ensemble de l'année
2020 et elle suppose que l'économie
française retrouvera son niveau d'avant
le confinement en trois mois seulement
nous considérons que ces prévisions sont
encore nettement trop optimistes alors
nous avons proposé une ou deux autres
courbes e2 et e3 qui simule tout d'abord
un arrêt plus important de l'économie
pendant la période du confinement et un
retour à l'activité qui sera nettement
plus lent elle donne des baisse du pib
allant de -10 % à - 12 et demi pour cent
pour 2020 et si pour la courbe eux deux
celle qui est en orange le retour à la
normale pourrait avoir lieu vers la fin
de l'année
grosso modo le mois d'octobre où le des
ou le début du mois de novembre n'en a
pas du tout de même pour la cour de 3
selon cette dernière la récession
induite justement par le confinement
pourrait aller au moins jusqu'au premier
semestre de 2021 alors du coup jacques
on imagine que cela aura des
conséquences sur les chiffres du chômage
oui tout à fait tout à fait olivier un
retour bien plus lent à l'activité
normale va mettre en péril
de très nombreuses sociétés qu'elles
soient petites ou qu'elle soit grande
sur les 11 millions de personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage partiel
un certain nombre ne retrouveront pas
leur emploi alors on va prendre trois
quarts tout d'abord le secteur de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie
c'est un secteur qui emploie en gros
près d'un million de personnes
nous craignons ici que le tiers d'entre
elles ne se retrouvent au chômage
avec la fin du confinement et du système
de chômage partiel qui a d'ailleurs été
annoncé comme devant prendre fin au
début du mois de juin
alors si on prend maintenant un deuxième
secteur à secteurs à haute technologie
comme l'industrie aéronautique et le
transport aérien
ici aussi les perspectives sont
mauvaises airbus pourrait mettre au
chômage près de 3000 salariés et au delà
si on accepte les prévisions qui sont
faites par les grandes compagnies
aériennes l'activité de ce secteur ne
retrouverait son niveau normal que d'ici
deux à trois ans enfin dans l'automobile
qui est aussi un secteur important pour
l'économie française
la baisse de la demande pourrait
contraindre tout le secteur à réduire la
voilure de manière considérable bref des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois seront perdus et encore plus
si l'on tient compte évidemment de
l'ensemble des sous-traitants et peut-on
chiffrer cet impact de la crise sur
l'emploi
alors oui oui on peut on peut
effectivement olivier entre les
nombreuses petites et moyennes
entreprises qui ne survivront pas un
déconfinement très progressif et les
entreprises qui ne pourront elles
survivre qu'au prix d'une réduction
importante de leur activité
on peut penser que d'ici la fin de
l'année une hausse du chômage d'au moins
500 mille personnes
luce sera inévitable alors si nous
avions à la fin de 2019 environ 4,3
millions de demandeurs d'emploi au
chômage et 7 millions de personnes qui
étaient dans une situation d'emploi de
très grande précarité
eh bien on peut craindre qu'à la fin de
ne soyons autour de 4,8 millions de
personnes au chômage et de 2 à 2,2
millions de personnes qui se retrouvent
dans cette situation d'emploi
extrêmement précaire ce qui veut dire
que l'ensemble des personnes dépendantes
de pôle emploi pourrait avoisiner les 7
millions en décembre 2020 autrement dit
cent mille personnes de plus que ce que
nous avions au deuxième trimestre de
2010 est c'est à dire au moment où
emmanuel macron a été ainsi jacques et
pour conclure après la vague de
l'épidémie il faut s'attendre à la vague
du chômage
oui c'est hélas exactement la situation
alors il faut comprendre que nous sommes
dans une crise qui est à double détente
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un moment
sanitaire de cette crise
mais ce moment sanitaire ne doit pas
masquer évidemment l'arrivée d'un moment
économique qui sera extrêmement
important et là il faut avoir toujours à
l'esprit le fait que oui bien sûr
c'était vite et millau pour a tué
beaucoup de gens peut-on plus de toutes
conditions sociales
il ya eu les députés comme patrick
devedjian ou même des chanteurs connus
comme christophe sauf que la crise
économique qui vient en tueur a aussi
beaucoup mais de cela on en parlera
moins six tentées même que l'on en parle
et qu'est ce que ce seront que c'est
mort et bien ce seront les morts de la
france ouvrière les morts de la france
active les morts de la france
périphérique
le confinement a eu sol tout comme effet
de
protéger la france des centres villes la
france des métropoles et c'était
nécessaire
on ne le conteste pas mais il faut
comprendre que c'est la france
périphérique qui va prendre à elle seule
le choc de la crise économique qui vient
merci jacques pour toutes ces
explications et cette analyse très
réaliste des conséquences de cette crise
sur l'emploi
à très bientôt sur rt france jacques
messi avoue olivier